ولكن في ملف ايراني اخر وهو الموازنه ففي
الوقت الذي يحتاج فيه الشارع على الاوضاع
المترديه تخرج الموازنه الايرانيه دون ان
تراعي المطالب الاساسيه اموالهم ضخمه يا
طاهر رصدها النظام لمؤسساته الامنيه
والدينيه بما لا يتمشى مع الوضعين
الانساني والاقتصادي المترددين في البلاد
فمثلا موازنه هذا العام تزيد على خمسه
الاف
ومئتين مليار اذا خمسه الاف يعني تتحدث عن
خمسه تريليونات ومئتين مليار تومان خصص
منها النظام بلخصص منها قرابه مئه وعشرين
الف مليار لميزانيه الحرس الثوري بزياده
مقدره بثمانيه وعشرين في المئه للجيش
نصيبه ايضا فقد رصدت زياده في ميزانيته
بالنسبه 36% وللشرطه زياده بنسبه 44% كما
تم رفعه ميزانيه المخابرات والسجون بمقدار
النصف
لم تتوقف عند هذا الحد بل طالت مؤسسات
دعايه والاعلام كمؤسسه الاذاعه والتلفزيون
اذا استفادت من زياده بلغت 42% ولا تقتصر
الدعايه على الاعلام واحتفل النظام نظام
الايراني منابر اخرى مثل
الحوزات على هذا رصد لحوزات قم وحدها فقد
حوالي تسعه الاف مليار تومانا
ضريح الخميني مثلا من زياده ما نسبته 71%
ومثل هذه الزيادات ضخمه في ميزانيات
المؤسسات ساعه النظام لتمريرها عبر الدفع
بزيادات في رواتب الموظفين وان كانت
بالنسبه لا تتجاوز 20 في المئه دائما ما
تسجل الحكومه عجزا بمقدار الثلث مثل ما
حدث في السنوات الاخيره ما ادى الى ذروه
الدين الحكومي ونمو التضخم الذي بلغ 40%
هذه المره سقط الحكومه مبررات مبنيه على
توقعات غير مضبوطات تفيد بان مداخلها
سترتفع من عائدات تصدير النفط والايرادات
الضريبيه